um yeah
so my name is david calhoun um
as you can read my talk is real time
satellite tracking in the browser
and not real time in the sense as the
last talk but
real time is that and that it's updating
and you can get the the current location
but not like the two-way you know nice
data binding
as described in the last talk but it's
cool stuff
um i'm doing some basic javascript i'm
not doing anything with emoji or
anything like that
so as people walk out the doors and like
um
sorry to disappoint you um but yeah i
work at a place called skybox imaging
and they wanted me to show you this
fancy slide with a bunch of numbers and
dollar signs and stuff i just wanted to
say like yeah we launched a satellite
last year which is pretty cool
a micro satellite and we're going to
launch one soon this year that's all i
want to say so
skip it okay so as for products
uh we sell some cool stuff we we we call
these sky nodes on the very left side
and we sell that to customers who
you know are interested in talking
directly to our satellites and actually
processing images on
server racks that they actually own and
control pretty cool so and we saw the
imagery and video and of course we have
like an analytics component of all of
that
it's cool we have the right in mountain
view we have a
clean room where we constructed the
satellites one of those is in space now
which is
pretty crazy to think about pretty smart
people work in there and
as just a front end or a ui engineer i
tend to think like at places like this i
i'm overwhelmed by the amount of
intelligence in the room but i'm also
overwhelmed at skybox because we have
basically like
rocket scientists and they talk about
words i've never heard before and i have
to go
look them up and everything so it's very
very humbling
very educational experience we have this
mission operations center which is right
in mountain view too and the screen in
the very back of the room actually i
helped develop that when i first joined
skybox it's a telemetry dashboard
so it's pretty awesome to see them
actually using that to to monitor
communications with the satellite as it
makes it pass about every 90 minutes
yeah and here's some cool stuff like
color infrared
and then we have this which is
where is it it's a little bit of a
special
slide there it goes
so that's actually not an image that's
actually a video
of the tallest building in the world as
a plane flies by in the front
so that's pretty amazing and that's real
parallax there it's not parallax
scrolling or anything like that sorry i
have to say these
corny jokes and i have to say we're
hiring so but
i don't want to take too much time santa
but as a ui engineer i get to work on
cool stuff so
i won't spend too much time doing this i
already mentioned the telemetry
dashboard
some of these are mapped based so it's
actually quite useful to understand some
of the orbitology and the orbital
mechanic
mechanics concepts behind the scenes
even if i don't fully understand the
math
which i don't i could actually i could
get the words and get the terminology
and just to understand
that is a huge leap so we'll see a
little bit of those concepts in
in this but nothing too crazy no heavy
math so my goal is like
to actually like present something that
everyone will be able to understand and
build
and um yeah i gave a link to the
to the uh to the talk actually online so
do a search for jsconf
um yeah and one of mine will be on the
top
i've uploaded the slides i've also
uploaded like step by step so you can
actually take this home and
and do it yourself nothing too crazy
going on
so i just want to step backwards
literally um for
like 50 years actually over 50 years ago
so you're standing in your backyard
enjoying the dark black sky the night
sky
that's supposed to happen that's okay
you know it's very early in the morning
or late at night
and you tune your ham radio into the
right frequency
and you know you look up and you see
this thing going across the sky and you
hear this do i have audio
uh i don't know if you can all hear this
but you hear this strange sound
i should have checked the audio first
anyway it's this telemetry signal
for something strange out there what the
heck is that it's
19 years 1957 who knows the name of what
it is
sputnik exactly so this guy this little
unimpressive guy and that's his only job
to send that telemetry signal out
and from the comfort of your own
backyard in america
wherever you are you can see this
soviet-built satellite
go up across you can see this and
potentially it can see you it doesn't
have any optics or anything
in the middle of the cold war freaky as
hell
like this you know this thing that could
be an icbm it could have some nuclear
payload
is going right right over your backyard
literally
so it it somehow you know it's like all
of a sudden
suddenly it becomes quite important to
know like what is this thing
and can i actually track where it's
going to be tomorrow and the next day
where is it where is it going to orbit
over that suddenly becomes important
and it becomes early front page news
so if you want to know if you want to
keep up to date this is your main source
as an
amateur you know person who has interest
in this and actually
back then everyone who had had an
interest in this because it's quite
important
and you get this one orbit track line it
shows you okay
there's the satellite but that's not
quite helpful it's like
okay at one point in time sometime
yesterday or something like that there
was where the satellite was
well where is it right now you know
isn't that more useful
so you keep up to date you check in
another newspaper and you see this thing
that gives you more details
so okay the satellite is going to cross
the 40th
parallel at these times which is
relevant for america
so it's like at those times you know you
can potentially go out in your backyard
and the soviets were were they were
honest in saying if you had a cheap pair
of binoculars and you point it in
just the right area it'd be extremely
difficult but you could actually see it
or you could see it with your eyes
reflect off the sun if it was just the
right
right timing but that's all you had
as your resources as an amateur you had
to rely on the newspaper
so like we can't really do that nowadays
when we
launch our satellites newspapers don't
really care there's a bunch of space
debris floating around up there people
you know newspapers aren't really
excited this is just because it was the
first time
and it was especially relevant for the
cold war
so let's fast forward back to oh about
last year in november
so should have oh damn
play there we go
oh crap it's an icbm actually
it's a decommissioned icbm oh stop
playing uh
it's a decommissioned icbm that's
actually used for commercial purposes
and our satellite went up on this with a
bunch of other micro satellites
and someone in my company had a good
point they said that the
the russians former soviets actually
turned into great capitalists
because they realized that they had all
these icbms lying around and they took
out the nuclear payload
um basically made contracts with
countries and companies and realized
they could profit like crazy off of this
so it turned out to be
fortuitous on both sides so pretty
amazing that we
we came from the blaze of sputnik and
then into the present day where we're
actually
past the cold war and actually doing
useful
things with this and commercial things
with it but the goal is still the same
it's like
back then you know i was working on a
project it happened to be a map-based
project that had orbit lines and
everything
but i really wanted to know okay how
difficult
is it for someone like someone normal
reasonably normal like me
who doesn't know a lot of math who knows
basic
well some javascript and can put some
stuff together and match things together
how difficult is that so that became my
goal as sort of like a hack date project
my goal is to plot this the current
position of skysat-1 which is
the name of our satellite stick it on a
map okay
let's see how far we can go so first we
need a map
that's useful we could use google maps
that's another option
we happen to use leaflet.js which is a
little more flexible it's like a nice
alternative
very customizable and this is what you
get straight out of the box this pretty
plain looking map with some
zoom controls nothing too fancy the code
for this is pretty simple
i copied it straight out of their
tutorial so there's nothing
fancy going on here i set a latitude
longitude which is just 0
0 to make it simple set a zoom level if
you've ever used google maps it's the
same concept
zoom of one just happens to be
completely zoomed out widest angle
possible
and then we add a tile layer which which
happens to be open street map tiles
and then that's what we get out of it
okay
that's all well and good but say we want
to customize the tiles and i don't like
those colors maybe
okay we have an option to use map box
tiles so mapbox is a service that takes
those open street
maps and and lets you customize it put
styles on it
not as simple as sort of like putting
css styles on it but they help you
with a little interface you can
customize it you can go crazy you can do
whatever you want with the colors on
here
as an example was something i wouldn't
recommend
hello kitty theme if you're really into
hello kitty oh that looks terrible okay
well
anyway that's hello kitty colors you can
go crazy and customize it it's up to you
it's up to your whim basically
it's pretty simple you log in create an
account you get a free
account to play around with you you say
create a project
which ends up being your satellite
tracker map and you get an api key there
so that just happens to be my key
so i i copy and paste it and paste it
into my init code
so now i can take out the actual vanilla
leaflet javascript include
dump in map boxes which is actually like
a wrapper around leaflet so it takes
care of everything for you
it's still leaflet but with some extra
functions on it and with map box tiles
which is sweet so i can customize it um
the initialization is
pretty much the same a little simpler
passing my ap
api key and i'm still passing in the lat
that long
and the zoom level so okay not too crazy
so we have our map now
we probably want to put a custom icon on
there for our satellite
so i just grabbed a little icon of
that's roughly what skysat-1 looks like
with this door open
it pops open when it's in space and
points down
and it's hovering over a location kind
of
somewhere in northern florida i have no
idea where that would be
probably around here so i i just took
the latte longitude from
amelia island plugged it in there and
then you can do it with this
don't let this frighten you if you're
new to javascript or anything it's super
simple
there's a basic example on the top so
you can say i just want to put like the
default leaflet map
marker on there at this latitude
longitude add it to my damn map and get
it over with
or you can say well i want a custom icon
so you can specify the path
you know there's even one now for the
retina or
you know high quality displays high
pixel density displays
specify the icon size and then the
anchor point
is actually where you want to position
where you want to map the
latitude longitude relative to your
actual icon
in this case we're just putting it smack
dab in the center some cases you might
want to put it in the upper left or so
forth but
keeping it simple now okay
all set i think we got everything we
need right
oh no actually okay we're kind of
missing some things we're missing math
some astrophysics probably we're missing
some more math in there just for good
measure
probably should throw that in there so
we it turns out we actually have to
backtrack a bit
um just to give you the concepts we have
to do
the fastest orbitology crash course in
the history and probably
not one of the best but that's cool
because you'll get a better
understanding of what's going on with
this math that we're going to use
so way back when when the earth was the
center of the universe
at least philosophically um
they actually made the math work but
with these crazy epicycle things
which end up looking like little
spirograph points so
this actually was a functional
mathematically like functional
working model to predict positions of
of planets and so forth but they knew
something was messed up
obviously you know the thing they had
they had a philosophy that things in the
heavens were perfect
it comes from philosophy it's like the
heavenly spheres and things
they're all perfect circles perfect
spheres obviously this model
doesn't have those perfect circles in it
so something is wrong with the model
but hey the math works so we'll stick
with it for
about a thousand years or so or longer
so until copernicus comes along and
actually the greeks
way before him actually believed in a
helocentric
sun-centered model of everything but
the the heliocentric model actually
rectified some of that
math so jumping past there
took until kepler kepler's first law
says okay well actually these orbits
that go around the sun aren't perfect
circles
turns out the heavens aren't perfect
after all sorry to break the news to
they're slight ellipses they're slight
when you look at them it looks almost
like
perfect circles but they're slight
ellipses and that makes the math work a
little better
but we still can't make the predictions
we can't plug in numbers and and predict
the position of where will this be at
this point in time
that took until newton and newton has
something called the
two body two body problem
okay so newton solved for the math for
this
i took out as much of the math as i
could on here there's still a little bit
but i took out the formulas
newton basically solved for this and
made this work so in this case we can
say
okay the blue thing in the middle is the
earth and that sky sat one around there
so he did the math for that
and that math is actually very elegant
works very well
in a system when there's only two bodies
but there's a problem
that's not actually reflective of
reality there's no actual
two-body system everything is connected
to each other gravitationally
everything's affecting each other
it turns out to be a huge problem with
the math and it
makes things a little crazy it's what
they're called it's what's called
perturbations to the orbit basically
perturbations are things that affect
that two-body problem
and the big things would be like the sun
the moon
the earth even the virtue of the earth
being oblate which is not a perfect
sphere
an oblate spheroid actually affects that
it's actually measured as a perturbation
in itself
it could be like atmospheric drag little
comets that go by
everything is related to itself so in
reality
we actually have an end body problem
there's so many things flying around out
there
that have an effect on this and if we
want a perfect model we have to throw
all of those into the math
into the perturbations formula which i
don't know how to do
i'm not that good at math and it's
literally like rocket science
so not a lot of people can do this but
there's books about it and you can get
the concept
so what's useful for us is that we have
the what's called
this simplified perturbations model
which is abbreviated as sgp4
and the formulas for these were actually
released in the 80s i think it was right
in 1980
originally in fortran which shows you
about how old that is
it's been ported to so many things since
then to java to see
to matlab even and of course now it's in
javascript people
port it to javascript
and when i say simplified you know maybe
it's like
someone's concept of simplified but that
does not appear to me to be like
simplified it's
it's scary stuff happening and yeah
this is from satellite js so this is a
port this is just a glimpse into the
file of what's actually going on
and they left the comments intact it
actually at the top of the code blocks
it still has comments
from the procedures from the fortran
code and from the port to c
plus bus so it's been ported like crazy
and every time it gets ported it has a
run
it has a series of tests that you can
test it against to make sure that the
math is still preserved even though it's
you know actually like a port but it's
pretty it looks pretty crazy
the good news is someone has already
ported that and we could theoretically
interface to it in an easy way which we
can
but we need inputs for those functions
so the sgp4 gives us the functions
we still need to put inputs into it and
what we use
as inputs are these things called tles
so they're two line element sets and i
show
a picture of a punch card which i also
saw way earlier this morning at the
at the beginning of the day um this is
where they originated
in punch card land in the in this in the
age of mainframe computers that were
churning and processing out all these
calculations
it turns out we still use the same
format so
even when we get to javascript land when
we ported everything all the way through
the tle still preserves the same format
as the punch card
it actually things are spaced out
exactly where they've been for
so long like you know decades and
decades
so it actually the format exactly
resembles it which is pretty cool
um yeah so and what i'm doing here is
i'm basically saying
okay the tle gives us some information
about the satellite at a certain point
of time
and because this is a simplified model
the math actually deviates over time
so when you have a tle for a certain day
it's been updated you get the updated
tle
you plug it into the system that the
math is going to deviate a little
there's going to be some drift day by
day so you have you have to keep the
tles up to date
and there's a place online where you can
get these for free called celeste track
actually if you just
do a search for um any satellite like
your favorite satellite
on google like skysat-1 tle or iss for
international space station tle
they all have tles that get updated very
frequently
because everyone plugs them into their
sgp4
models um you know and they and this is
useful information it shows us
the parts of the it shows us a little
bit about the orbit
what's called eccentricity inclination
all these things you could look up i'm
not going to explain it
eccentricity is interesting one actually
tells you how far does that orbit
deviate from a perfect circle
so there's there's no perfect circles of
course
but there's there also there's crazy
orbits like for spy satellites that
actually
are hugely eccentric that actually the
orbit
goes way out here and it come when it
comes back around the earth
it gets quite close to the earth and the
purpose is exactly for spying purposes
that's his one purpose it goes way the
way the heck around
comes swings around really fast close to
the earth and comes out again
so that number would be quite different
but yeah that gives you an
idea of what those represent i do have a
little tool down there i have a link to
it so
you can check it out after but i do have
a tool that kind of helps you
like educate yourself about how this
breaks down
the first line turns out to be more
descriptive it doesn't change much it
tells you what the satellite number is
um like the year it was launched is that
13.
66 is the is the number of the launch
for that year
c is the piece of that launch so we were
also launched with dubai sat
and some other satellites that have a
different number they might be
b or d or something like that 14
is the is the year that the tle was
generated
so it's in this year and then 148.177
it's a fractional number for what day of
the year is it out of 365 days
so it's quite descriptive and you can
see when it gets out of date by
you know checking that so
that's our input that's what we need we
have all the raw materials and we just
have to mash them together now
we're really like standing on the
shoulders of giants so now at this point
okay we plug them into our functions so
we need to get
sgp sgp4 functions
in javascript and we have a couple
options i found these two main ones
there's this one thing called isat
which is a nice nasa-based
satellite viewer the end result of it is
actually a webgl based
nice 3d globe and it plots the position
of any
satellite on there i didn't use it
because it's not like a standalone
sgp4 library
it's actually and it's not actually an
active development it has a lot of tests
and it looks like everything's pretty
pretty accurate but it's like okay it's
just not in development now so
i kind of want to keep my hands off of
that and i am using satellite.js
alternatively because it's still an
active development the api
is not perfect but you know it's getting
better
um you know and it serves a single
purpose the purpose that i want
so how do we interface to this it turns
out to be not
as clean of an api as we wanted like
ideally
i have to write this little helper
wrapper function this thing that don't
let this frighten you nothing
complicated is happening here
it's called a function called getsat
that long
so i'm going to plug in a tle i'm going
to plug in an optional local time
uh if i don't pass in a local time it's
going to default to whatever is now
and then it's going to take that local
time and this is an important step you
have to convert that to utc time
which is roughly equivalent to gmt time
um
there's one catch here you have to
there's a off by one thing in the
library so
so you have to add one to the javascript
month
the the months in javascript are zeroth
base so you just add one
and everything is happy after that and
then there's a lot more to this function
actually below
but it's straight up copied from the
readme so i didn't really do that much
work here i just have to like
sanitize it massage the data a little
bit all i did is write a nice little
wrap around for it
and this is an example of the usage i
plugged in our tle for the skyset one
um just plugging it right into the
function so what that's going to return
is an array of lat lawn of the
current position of the satellite
because i didn't pass in at time i can
optionally
pass in whatever time i want so i could
say in one hour
what's going to be the lawn and it will
give that
then i'm gonna do a simple interval on
it
um nothing too fancy every two seconds
update it
and for that leaflet marker update the
latitude longitude
and we get something that looks like
ah i'm having a problem
with the videos here
damn you get something that should be
this
ah very slight slightly moving along
there
and i put a nice little css transition
animation on it so every two seconds it
gets updated and it kind of jumps a
little
so all i did because leaflet behind the
scenes is doing a translate 3d
i know i can animate that in css and i
just
put a little transition on it a two
second transition
so technically the position is a little
off by
two seconds but it's accurate enough
where you get the idea and it looks
it moves pretty gracefully across the
screen okay that's cool and it's
supposed to stop there because it's a
video
um now it would be nice probably to have
an orbit line
just because that would be nice where
where has the orbit been
you know for a period of time and where
is it going to be
that's actually quite useful could be
useful for humanitarian purposes too we
know there's like some event in some
country
and we want to see okay we know skysat
is an imaging satellite we want to see
when's the next opportunity
when we can actually take an image of
that country when
when's the next pass gonna be so this
turns out to be quite useful
so we can generate what we call a ground
track which is just a basic orbit line
nothing too fancy going on here too so
don't be afraid
um the steps are basically
how many so so we're going to we're
going to piggyback on the thing that's
right at the very end of this function
which is a polyline
leaflet polyline accepts an array of
latitude longitudes
and plots them on a polyline
and so we have to generate all those
latitude longitudes and we have to
generate them by step
intervals so i'm going to say let's do
one minute intervals because that should
be a
pretty enough line especially when we're
zoomed out it should be pretty smooth
and we're going to have a time offset so
i'm just going to say
give me three hours in the past and give
me three hours
in the future and plot this orbit line
for me
stick him into this array that's what
that while loop is doing
and stick the polyline on the screen
give it a blue color
and we get something that's a little
ugly
so it turns out leaflet has this problem
uh when the map wraps around and also
when the map goes
across the international date line it's
this famous source of headaches and all
the
the computations where that breaks off
there just happens to be
the international date boundary so you
can see the lines at the bottom
obviously aren't correct it's not going
to
jump across there but with some further
refinements you can get it to a point
where it's a little cleaner than that
there's also some like
some distortion there's some built-in
distortion into these maps actually
because this is a
this is a projection of a 3d space of a
sphere so there's gonna
there's actually a huge distortion at
the poles and you can see a little bit
of that because our step function
isn't precise enough and near the poles
you can see actually
like the lines become even more jagged
that's actually an indication of the map
distortion
and that sort of leads to what would be
the next steps with what do i do with
this like
it actually turns out to be more useful
i don't have time to get into it but you
it's actually more intuitive if you go
to 3d maps
because you can see the orbits that
actually intuitively logically make more
sense
these orbits are kind of crazy because
they're a map projection it doesn't
seem right but with this you have you
have a couple tools there's one out
there called ccm
cesium this is what powers that what i
was talking about before i sat
it kind of does all the fun work for you
so
you don't have to do you can customize
it but you don't have to do
terribly a lot of work there's another
one that's more customizable with 3ds
which is more of a webgl type of example
and there's this awesome tutorial
that someone other than me did online
they start with a sphere
and 3gs put a little texture around it
put
put the map texture around it stretch it
around they get some clouds as a
separate layer that they can animate
separately
and the nice thing about 3js i don't
have it here but you can plug in cad
models in here
so i actually found like the cad model
on the shared drive somewhere of the
satellite
which we've actually like we we don't
have it there anymore and i can't show
it to you because of
you know restrictions but i i was able
to plug in that cad model it was way too
big for my purposes because it had all
the little detailed components about the
satellite inside
but that actually worked very slowly on
here and i could see it floating around
up there so that's what you can
springboard off of you can do
all sorts of stuff and everyone should
be able to go through the examples
again i have the link posted there jscon
it's bitly slash jsconf dash
satellite and that shows all the steps
that corresponds to my slides
through step one to the end so everyone
should be able to load that up and be
able to tweak it and play around with it
yeah ping me on on twitter if you have
any questions or any questions about
what i've been working on
happy to to answer so yeah that's about
it thank you for
thank you for listening
so
you